[Applause]
[Music]
North Korea is perhaps the most emetic
closed off an isolated country on the
planet a country that now in 2018 seems
to be living in 1960
[Music]
[Applause]
however now this entire story it might
be about to change
here at visual politic we've already
talked about how capitalism is reaching
North Korea by following popular markets
how an entire entrepreneurial revolution
is taking place and how today more than
50% of North Koreans make a living from
the private economy however a couple of
questions remains on the table what does
one of the most totalitarian governments
on the planet think about this
particular capitalist revolution what
are his plans and another very very
important question who the help would be
willing to invest in North Korea well
listen up
[Music]
these aren't the best of times
On June the 12th 2018 historic meeting
was held in Singapore for the first time
the US president in this case Donald
Trump met with a North Korean leader so
why
well supposedly this was 2d nuclearized
North Korea
[Music]
[Applause]
perhaps the actual goal well in addition
to taking a couple of pictures I mean a
picture's never hurt the idea was to
start a dialogue and cool down the
enormous tension that had been growing
between the two countries and preventing
North Korea from continuing with a
nuclear program that could have given it
the ability to attack even the United
States well hold on a moment because you
know one thing's theory and another
thing is truth I mean check out the
latest news US spy agency's North Korea
is now working on new missiles Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo acknowledged during
Senate testimony that North Korea
factories continue to produce fissile
material used in making nuclear weapons
[Music]
and nowadays as we told you here on
visual politic it seems very difficult
for the Pyongyang regime to agree at
least in the short term to get rid of
its nuclear weapons which are after all
of their best life insurance but of
course that doesn't mean they won't
accept making concessions to normalize
their relations with the rest of the
world and end the international
sanctions because you see since Kim
jong-un came to power in 2011 he said
two priorities on the one hand develop a
nuclear bomb and on the other something
far less sinister reforming the economy
yes you heard that right although it
seems hard to believe one of the
objectives that Kim jong-un the North
Korean dictator has set himself is to
change his country's bad economic
situation by copying some of the changes
that have taken place in countries like
China and Vietnam
and check this out once they develop
their nuclear capabilities kyeong
Young's number one priority is precisely
this to advance in economic development
of course to achieve this they need to
end international sanctions which are
causing enormous damage yes we'll see
how that it may seem hard to believe
North Korea's situation could get even
worse for example between the sanctions
and the sinking of Venezuela one of the
few countries that had allied itself
with North Korea relations have
collapsed but of course when we talk
about North Korea and the economy we
need to talk about China 80 percent of
all North Korean trade and foreign
exchange occurs here and what's happened
is that China has been pushing Pyongyang
for years to get some reforms going once
and for all and since those changes have
been slower than a turtle with
rheumatism well last year Beijing
decided to start applying international
sanctions this is what was happening in
August of 2017 China to implement UN
sanctions on North Korea China banned
North Korean iron lead and coal imports
as part of UN sanctions as you can
imagine considering the enormous
dependence that North Korea has on China
this has been a disaster just in the
first six months of 2018 Chinese
purchases of North Korean products have
plummeted by more than 90 percent and
Chinese exports to North Korea by 40
percent
[Music]
all of this of course is in the official
market and as we've seen there is a
parallel market for the black market and
that's an entirely different story the
fact is that all this has led North
Korean industrial and mining production
to go through its worst time in recent
years and if we add the disastrous state
of the country's infrastructure to all
of this with that continuous blackouts
less than a thousand kilometers of paved
roads throughout the country and
decrepit trains that in many cases don't
go over 20 kilometers or 12 miles per
hour it's clear that this country
urgently needs a 180 degree turn and you
know what they also know in Pyongyang
North Korea become the new Vietnam in
1986 Vietnam launched the well-known joy
mode policy a set of economic reforms
similar to those of den shopping in
China these had the mission of setting
communism aside in order to jumpstart a
market economy to achieve this
agricultural cooperatives were dissolved
price controls were eliminated land
ownership was allowed and policies were
put in place to attract foreign
investment so what was the result of all
of this well over the following 30 years
of Vietnam's economy grew at an average
annual rate of almost 7 percent today
Vietnam is transforming at a breakneck
speed and its exports are already larger
than those of countries like Brazil or
Australia
well at the last inter-korean summit in
April between Kim jong-un and the
president of South Korea moon jaein the
North Korean leader expressed an
interest in following the model of
Vietnam and following this line the
North Korean government has approved
some significant measures in recent
years for example it has promoted the
creation of private markets has given
more autonomy to public companies it has
granted land parcels to peasants for
private exploitation however despite all
of this there aren't two questions which
we need to answer who on earth would be
willing to invest in North Korea and
what else is the pyongyang government
willing to do well listen up would
invest in North Korea
if you were asked which countries you
would like to do business in North Korea
would probably be one of your last
options investing in such a totalitarian
comes from where the leader makes and
unmix laws at will where the government
acts with brutality and dedicates itself
to threatening the rest of the planet
investing in a country where the rule of
law and legal security as pure fantasy I
mean come on
well folks the truth is they're not
everyone sees it this way see some of
South Korea's largest companies such as
hi owned a lot corporation and Samsung
have already set up work groups to
investigate and analyze the potential
business opportunities in North Korea
and according to polls three-quarters of
South Korean companies would be willing
to do business in North Korea if
sanctions were lifted
Kyodai for example is already preparing
an early reopening of the industrial
Thai song zone an industrial zone next
to the border of South Korea that was
created in 2004 to house foreign
companies mainly South Korean and which
employs more than 80,000 North Koreans
but in 2013 given the growing tensions
between the two Koreas it was closed by
the Pyongyang government even recently
Jim Rogers one of the most important and
well-known investors of all time has
lamented the fact that the United States
doesn't allow him to invest in North
Korea and has made statements such as
these Korea is now going to be the most
exciting country in the world
Kim jong-un does not want war Kim is not
North Korean he was educated in
Switzerland he knows there's a different
world out there they need everything
electricity so tablecloths if you've got
any kind of expertise you're going to
make a fortune
Jim Rogers but hold on just a moment the
question we have to ask ourselves is
well what the hell do they see in a
country like North Korea well
fundamentally they see opportunities
[Music]
North Korea has a very young and very
entrepreneurial population with low
labor costs in addition the country
seems to be quite rich in natural
resources it's got gold zinc copper and
rare earth elements the estimated value
of all of these minerals could be more
than six billion dollars then as Jim
Rogers says the country is still being
built it needs everything and if that
wasn't enough it's also located between
two economic powers China and South
Korea you see at the last inter-korean
summit the South Korean president gave
Kim jong-un a pen drive that included
lots of the investments that South Korea
would be willing to make do you know
what investments were included on this
pendrive
well Seoul would be very interested in
building trans Korean railroads that in
addition to boosting the North Korean
economy would allow South Korea to
export goods much more quickly to China
and it's the same story with roads all
pipe lines etc these would be
billion-dollar plans of course not
everything is so simple and enthusiasm
is far from widespread North Korea is a
brutal dictatorship corruption is huge
and the government can do literally
whatever it wants for example it can
expropriate but we are yakking [ __ ]
amantha Sakura this is where the money
is to be made if you can figure out how
to not get expropriated just in Hastings
an associate professor at the University
of Sydney and then of course there's the
issue of international sanctions as a
consequence of their nuclear program and
until those are lifted any change is
going to have a very short run now it's
precisely at this point that China can
play a very important role
you see Xi Jinping has managed to do
what China's been planning for years
getting Kong yang going which could
obviously mean a lot of big business for
Chinese companies that's why we now see
headlines like this
China suggests sanctions relief for
North Korea after Trump Kim summit and
not only that China has allowed the
black markets between both countries to
flourish its accelerated the development
plans in the border area and is already
studying the imminent opening of special
economic zones on the North Korean
border and then there's tourism which is
one of Kim jong-un's government's
greatest priorities listen up North
Korea a holiday spot the arrival of
Chinese tourists has continued in recent
years and since May 2018 the number of
daily arrivals has more than doubled
you're going to run at least seven or
eight tour routes to North Korea this
year including a one-day tour to nanyo
and a trip of four to five days to
Pyongyang Kaesong & Panmunjom changing
the deputy manager of a Chinese travel
company
well tourism is precisely one of the
pyongyang government's top priorities
for several reasons first it generates
employment remember this is a very
labor-intensive sector it also attracts
investments that helps obtain foreign
currency very quickly
on the other hand tourism could change
the regime's image and the truth is that
swapping nuclear parades and nuclear
threats with exotic beaches and seaside
dinners that's gonna be good for
business
due to this in 2014 the Korean
government created the special tourist
zone of one Sun a special economic zone
where foreign investment is allowed and
where in principle the regime would
allow more freedom for developing
tourism yes this is the same area where
until recently the Army did things like
this you know North Korean things
[Music]
the fact is that with the nuclear
program and the sanctions results have
been very scarce however Kim jong-un he
wants to step on the gas without going
any further in 2017 the North Korean
government sent a delegation to Spain
which is one of the major tourist powers
of the world in order to check out
places like Benidorm or morena door the
idea was that this delegation would
learn from them and get some ideas
apparently Pyongyang's goal is to
attract more than 1 million tourists per
year in the short term and 5 to 10
million more in the foreseeable future
the question is will Kim jong-un really
be willing to carry out all of the
reforms that the country needs to get
these plans to come to life well folks
only the future is gonna be able to
answer that question for now what seems
clear is that we have the best
opportunity to leave the North Korean
nightmare behind which isn't only a
threat to the rest of the world but
above all it's a punishment and a great
prison of fear and repression for the
North Koreans themselves but now it's
your turn are you in favor of lifting
sanctions against North Korea well leave
your answer in the comments below as
well as in this survey and I really hope
you enjoyed this video please do hit
that like button if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
also don't forget to check out our
friends of the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and also of course
this channel is made possible because of
our patreon and our patrons on that
platform please do consider joining them
and helping us in our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]